Gregg I'll go to you at you have a
theory well no it's not a theory but
kind of a you know this is obviously a
terrorism and it's a terrorist but we
have to admit that this kind of Terror
as opposed to Islamic terror it is still
kind of a religious fervor or terror
except it's the media that is the
religion that promises the afterlife why
do people do this it's not to get 72
virgins it's to get 72 million hits on
their Wikipedia page if you if the
motive is always growing your numerical
significance through infamy and with
technology one angry loser one angry
loser can get in the record books by
doing this because you had a country
paralyzed and and if you you know decide
in life that life isn't worth living and
that you hate everybody around you this
is the way to get there it's evil evil
through the media provides a consistent
reward and and if you know it used to be
in the old days if you lived in a small
town you had a community that provided
you with your feeling of Worth and for a
lot of people who are isolated and and
they're in they're bad people this is
their reward one thing we don't know yet
Jesse and will continue to monitor that
press conference is motive do you think
that there's anything in his background
mean this has no criminal record it was
not in the military he was home-schooled
by his mom no political party on his
voter registration but a guy that it was
an electrical engineer gone bad very bad
yeah I mean a college dropout lived with
two roommates who they're talking to and
supposedly they're being very
cooperative had a house yeah they better
be this Texas law enforcement guys
aren't gonna take it too easy on him if
they know something there were some
writings that we believe came from this
person he was talking about he was
against gay marriage or something about
being for the death penalty he said he's
not a political person
I guess he said he leans conservative we
don't know yet if that was the
motivation if it was political if
there's a manifesto out there we'll know
more about that we haven't heard
anything about that yet but just to go
back to Kimberly's point we've
criticized law enforcement and the
and on multiple levels for years whether
it's police brutality whether it's these
shootings that were botched
investigations or FISA abuse and this is
one of those moments where you have to
say you guys just did an amazing job to
piece together this with the speed that
they did by looking at the receipts and
then matching the surveillance footage
and these batteries that were ordered
from Asia I believe were very exotic and
then to ping his phone and to see his
Google search history and do that within
a really tight time span and then get
his car and then tail him until he blew
himself up I mean we were thinking that
this could go on for a while the
Unabomber went on for years I mean this
guy was over in a short amount of time
and law enforcement just did an amazing
job so I just want to say
congratulations to you guys and into the
people of Austin it's such an amazing
city I visited there several times
beautiful people there and a great
spirit and I do they don't have to be
you know breathing a sigh relief yet but
I think the worst is behind us and it's
just amazing that I can think now they
can take a breath one they're in
Pflugerville his mother father and two
sisters also lived and apparently they
said that they had no idea and they you
know sent their prayers to the victims
in that reminder of you know what we saw
after the Vegas terror people said they
had no idea even the girlfriend in that
case no idea so in this case though I
think that everyone is going to be just
as in the Vegas case hungry for motive
trying to understand but the larger
picture to me is that we seem to have
more of these kinds of incidents whether
it's with guns or bombs in American
society today so everybody's looking at
this when they put it in the category of
the Unabomber or the Olympic Park bomber
or I just guess there was something
called a Midwest pipe bomber to all of
these different bombings but I just
think it's you know we see more of these
outbreaks of kind of violence and too
often you know we young men and then we
have arguments and conversations about
the violence in our media in our
Hollywood stories in our video games and
the like but also mental health but
something's going on and it's hard to
get away from it and hard not to worry
may I respond to that
young men are responsible for violence
but they're also responsible for a lot
of things you know what I mean
and and when you when you go no I'm just
saying that like did they're there they
fight our Wars yes
and they're also respond but you can't
just say this is a this is a male issue
the good news here is that whenever
anybody's doing a story on this they go
the relevant point in in history is the
Unabomber that's actually good news
because that was 20 years ago so this
actually isn't common it's actually rare
the fact that you have to go back and
look for that something that what's like
this oh it's the Unabomber and they have
to go back to 95 I think or 94 when he
was Scott so there is some kind of I
think that's encouraging we also know
that violence is on the decline we know
that and to your point to that you've
made before about evil and how we
compare this cut of domestic terrorism
to Islamic terrorism in the United
States I think the Islamic terrorism is
more fearful on our behalf because it's
about an overall philosophy and ideology
that's worldwide and has goals to take
over the world whereas this is something
like you know this is a deranged kid he
doesn't fit into a category there's no
way to kind of put them into a category
and then attack him through certain
angles what are you supposed to do a
better person like this well I hope I
don't know I hope we can but there are
strategies neutralized Islam and I think
that's one of the things that we're
starting to have to understand that we
have to be better we have to pick up on
signals more quickly to see I think
that's part of it and Greg I agree it's
about you know young men fight our Wars
too but I don't think there's any
question I don't see women doing no of
course but that's yeah obviously I mean
if you look at prisons yeah how many
women are in prison right but what I'm
saying is like when you say okay this is
a problem we yet what are white males
and what are males in general they are
at a certain age are high testosterone
creatures and they are available I mean
there are they are often involved in a
lot of things they say and our producers
have been monitoring the press
conference Kimberly they say they don't
have a motive yet last word to you
basically there's a lot of evidence
in that home basically a treasure trove
and they're gonna be able to go through
and understand and get a very deep
picture of who he is we was
communicating with what might have
motivated him was behind this so that's
that the good news is we're gonna learn
we get some understanding from this it
was stopped at an early juncture which
is critical especially for someone who
seemed so furious and fanatic in terms
of trying to turn these bombs out and do
destruction I'm very sad for the victims
and the certainly families less than the
families